depuis un an déjà la guerre civile fait
rage en ethiopie un pays de quelque 115
millions d'habitants et de plus de 80 et
nuit jusqu'à maintenant il ya toujours
eu un homme fort qui dominait le pays
appuyé sur une ethnie ou le parti d'une
ethnie jamais ses 90 se sont réunis
d'une façon ou d'une autre pour décider
par quelle institution par quel système
vivre ensemble un conflit armé oppose le
gouvernement fédéral dhabi ahmed et le
flp t le front de libération du peuple
du tigré
le tigre est une région de l'extrême
nord de l'ethiopie qui compte à peu près
6 % de la population une guerre
fratricide mais aussi une guerre contre
le fédéralisme et deux camps qui campent
sur leurs positions
et c'est ça qui est aujourd'hui en jeu
les talents d'un côté la système
centralisé en disant n'y a que de cette
façon là que nous réussirons à obtenir
le pays et ça c'est la position de habib
armes est le premier ministre et de
l'autre ceux qui disent non le seul
moyen de continuer à vivre ensemble
c'est une très forte décentralisation
fédéralisme ethnique avec une forte
domination al le flp t a renforcé ses
positions avec la création d'une
alliance de neuf organisations rebelles
issus d'ethnies et de régions
différentes
une alliance contre le premier ministre
a bien med signé à washington
selon le mode for hp rien ne nous
arrêtera a dit le représentant des
rebelles tigréens qui accusent le
premier ministre de mobiliser le peuple
contre son mouvement
[Musique]
depuis l'été les rebelles tigréens ont
repris le contrôle de leurs territoires
s'étendant même au delà avec l'aide du
groupe armé allié oromo il affirme être
aux portes de la capitale addis abeba
mais cette alliance serait à double
tranchant les deux plus grands acteurs
de cette alliance est à dire les digues
réa et les eurobonds ont entre eux une
histoire conflictuelle extrêmement
lourde et que cicatriser cette histoire
ne va pas être ça
des dizaines de milliers d'éthiopiens
sont sortis dans les rues dans un effort
pro gouvernemental de mobilisation
dont l'ethiopie ne sera pas désintégré
et ira toujours de l'avant affirme cette
femme qui dit vouloir protester contre
les groupes terroristes et les jantes
ceux qui nous ont harcelé pendant les 27
dernières années dit m
[Musique]
car le flp t a fait partie du pouvoir de
1991 à 2000 18 devant la résurgence des
tensions la diplomatie africaine et
américaine s'active en coulisse tentant
de ramener les deux frères ennemis à la
table des négociations
avait charmé bas exige que les trous
qui sont en région amara se retire et
les guérillas existe le blocus
les combats dans le tigré ont fait des
milliers de morts et des centaines de
milliers de déplacés plongeant le nord
de l'ethiopie dans une grave crise
humanitaire selon l'onu au moins quatre
cent mille personnes sont au bord de la
famine au tigré où aucune aide n'a pu
parvenir doper le 18 octobre ici à ce
mitraillage radio canada montréal